[Music]
metaverse nft virtual reality the first
edition of digital art fair asia shows a
new generation of artists
as digital art fair we're particularly
interested in educating the new
generation archaeology and even
traditional architecture to enter the
new digital world
the fair features over 200 digital and
nft artworks from turkish artist graphic
and adults metaverse nft collection to
images paying tribute to hong kong's
architecture
i feel like
the digital art space has slowly been
evolving
i think social media plays a huge part
in society these days and instagram got
way bigger from when i first arrived
we have surreal hong kong surreal is a
very talented photographer that likes to
elevate his photography by using
photoshop techniques we have the work of
blair sugarman and jsr pixel they're
doing light paintings with drones so
they've actually programmed the drones
to
to do the shape around iconic hong kong
buildings so in the photography section
we sell nfts which are available on this
screen you have to scan the qr code and
it takes you to refinables website there
you pay an ethereum and you have to have
a wallet
this is a new way of purchasing artwork
nft or non-fungible token runs on
blockchain technology unlike bitcoins
each nft can be a unique digital
property and one nft can represent
ownership of a specific work of art
nft's ability to comfort uniqueness has
led to a boom in digital arts
collectibility
nft art started making headlines in
march when christie's auctioned a
collage of images by artist people to a
singapore-based crypto investor who paid
69.3 million dollars worth of ether
zabotage whose work encompasses street
art and stencil started offering nft in
hong kong last november
not so much the 2d anymore it's not even
3d it's even 4d you can you can get the
whole story of how you approach your
work and your process and your methods
a report from blockchain development
company consensus says the nft art
market was up more than 800 percent from
52 million dollars at the end of 2020 to
490 million dollars in april 2021
christie's announced in september that
it had shattered the 100 million dollar
ceiling in nft sales worldwide with its
first nft auction in asia hitting a
total of 15.6 million dollars in sales
and outside of asia switzerland's art
basel had its first nft auction the same
month
but nft's soaring popularity has also
raised concerns some critics are calling
it just another commercially exploitable
hype while others point to suspicions of
wash trading and there's also the
ecological impact
still that's not phasing artists and
collectors
i'm totally excited about the whole talk
that's going with this phenomenon at the
moment it's a new field a new playing
field and
i'm out there playing an experiment
i think the world is really ready for
promoting digital artists trying to
understand what's energy and the gallery
is actually getting ready to jump in the
end of the world
[Music]